[Music]
okay so I'm Alex I'm from New Relic we
are based here in Barcelona and today I
want to share a little bit our story of
using after streams in production
systems so I work in the cloud
monitoring part that is completely built
here in Barcelona and if you squint
about cloud monitoring it's not that
complicated right we have a cloud
provider that you have your application
and we basically do an HTTP request to
fetch the metrics for all our clients
and these metrics we send towards a
Kafka topic and it ends up in our
internal database not a big deal now the
architecture as we did of this project
is basically a task queue which means
that there is a scheduler that knows
when to push which jobs into the Kafka
topic and there is a worker that picks
these jobs from the topic and it
executes them so it allows us to do is
to have multiple workers obviously that
all of them are separated and don't
share anything and they all pick up
things from the Kafka topic and they
execute the HTTP requests now this color
in this situation would be a single
point of failures or we fixed it
introducing several instances of
scheduler each one of them though there
is only one of them that is scheduling
things and they lead election the one
that will be scheduling is down to the
zookeeper so as you see this
architecture has several key points its
horizontally scalable in all the points
so we can add more workers whenever we
need to bomb the throughput we can its
stateless meaning that the worker shares
nothing between them and so it makes the
horizontal scalability actually possible
it's failsafe meaning that if one worker
dies nothing happens it's gonna be
replaced and no data will be lost if
scheduler dies nothing happens the
another one will be elected as a leader
and the work will keep flowing and there
are a few Kafka topics involved
so in Uralic so it is happened that
Kafka became a backbone communication
pipeline for our back-end services so
whenever we can allow the synchronous
communication there is normally Kafka in
place so when we are same metrics as one
very same metrics what we mean basically
is that ok so you have your entity it
could be an ec2 instance and can be in
Kafka topic and can be whatever and it
would have a timestamp which basically
means that we took the measurement at
this point in time and it's gonna be
symmetric it can be CPU number of
partitions memory what-have-you
and these metrics are arriving in time
one by one with some resolution and all
these metrics as I said we send two
words energy B so the from this storage
perspective and when you think about it
it's kind of it becomes a little bit
expensive to store all the data with one
minute resolution so at some point the
normal request comes that you have to do
the aggregation of the data and to
produce just for example for historical
purposes one event for an hour in our
case it gonna means that we have to
introduce state which is something that
we really didn't like to introduce
because our system was perfect it was
architecture it was horizontal is
capable everything was working the state
is the bummer
basically so the way we wanted to
achieve it is whenever we have an
architectural problem we never end up
create any new Kafka topic so in this
case we would listen to the one-minute
resolution metric topic and we would do
the aggregation and we send it towards
one our resolution top
end up in energy be also we looked at
several approaches of how you can do it
like the classical approach is to just
do the batch processing in Uralic
historically budge didn't work very well
whenever we do something in budge for
the client data we end up rewriting it
in string because of like the main
challenge for us is the sheer scale of
data like there is just too much data
that we're trying to ingest in process
so and the we have some requirements on
the latency so budge approach didn't
work well local storage is not an option
because the worker will just like if the
worker dies we lose the data of the
client which is not good so like
failsafe go out the window and it was
not an option
the last resort of any architects like
summon readies in case of doubt and this
situation also couldn't help us because
there is just too much data for Eddie's
and we would have to go into sharding
and partitioning and everything and this
not something that we wanted to do so we
asked around in your Alec to understand
what other teams are doing because this
is not the first time we're trying to
solve this problem and the two answers
we got was Apache flink and Kafka
streams that already were used by some
teams in your attic so both of these
systems provide exactly one semantics
which is great it basically means that
your message is guaranteed to be
processed once and only once both of
them provides stateful local storage
with this failsafe mechanism meaning
that if your worker dies the storage is
guaranteed to be restored somewhere else
and so you're good to go
the difference started more on the
operational side of the things as I said
Kafka being the backbone of New Relic
it's been provide to us developers as a
service meaning that there is a special
team that takes care of our huge Kafka
cluster and what we do is we just create
pull requests they're requesting our
topics with all the configuration that
we need and in case of a fling we would
have to manage our run cluster of link
which is for a small team as we are is
not something we prefer to do and
another big difference between these two
string processors is the flink is a
framework playing brings everything with
it you basically give it a cluster like
give it the resources and it takes care
of networking and takes care of storage
it takes care of scheduling jobs of
executing them everything everything the
flink is the whole world and in order to
work with it well you have to understand
it so it's I think there's like for us
at least there was a steep learning
curve because as I said we already knew
Kafka and Kafka streams is basically a
library in abstraction on top of the
cafe itself so like no new concepts have
to be learned for us when you introduce
Kafka streams library so when you just
work with Kafka you have consumer and
producer libraries in your application
and you manage them by itself one need
to reduce Kafka streams Kafka streams
takes away from you the consumer and
producer and it gives you the
abstractions like source and sync and
all the tables and streams and gives you
the DSL to manipulate them so from the
operational perspective we could use the
same deployment mechanism which was
great and weekly and like no new
external dependencies will appear for us
which basically means that we could go
to production quickly so now having like
all the tools on
and we were ready to work with sunstate
so as I said the project we were trying
to tackle was the aggregation when you
work with Kafka streams in your
application and you start some stateful
operation like for example aggregating
the data character streams gives you an
abstraction of tor and behind the scenes
this store is backed by the changelog
topic this is the way cop-car streams
achieves this fails tape storage right
so whatever information is in your local
store it can be in memory or it can be
rocks DB will also be backed up to this
Kafka topic so the metric arrives with
the max value of like 10 in this
situation we process it and we store it
and it's automatically being sent to the
changelog topic the new one arrives it's
been updated and by the end of the hour
we produce the last metric that we saw
when you need to bump up the throughput
because you need to process more things
and you add more instances in place what
will happen Kafka will give each of
these instances its own store it's local
but it also gonna create underneath
three in this case partitions of the
changelog each one for its own store
since using the magic of consumer group
all the things are being united in like
one consumer group and they're consuming
from the same topic if one of them dies
it's not a problem
the tote the partition that has been
lost will be picked up by them by some
other instance and this store will be
migrated to this instance so this
instance will just read everything from
this Kafka topic that he saw by the time
and it will be ready to start from the
same point when the previous instance
died so in case of the aggregation in
this project what we got basically was
the key value storage
if you think about it it's it could be a
generic key value storage like you can
use it wherever you want not like not
only the way that Kafka gives you it
automatically but also like if you do
custom transformers you can use the
storage we got for free time window
calculations and this is something that
we really didn't want to do ourselves
because time is hard like whenever you
try to do the time with the calculation
you find out that you just need to write
too many tests in order to make it work
you're we got scalability with the
number of partitions and this is one of
the key points of Kafka streams
basically that you can scale infinitely
if you just add infinite number of
partitions technically there is a
physical limit I think in the cluster
but I don't know which one it is and as
I said we got a bunch of new Kafka
topics and this is a recurrent topic
okay so this project was went quite well
in terms that we were happy with chosen
technologies so we decided to tackle the
next one
the next one was about the data
enrichment in the old days is basically
when you have to go to look for the
information in the database well this is
now called enrichment so with AWS the
trick is that you always have several
api's one API will give you the metrics
and the other API will give you what we
call metadata will be a region your
instance name your instance type what
have you and what we wanted to do is
basically to merge two streams of data
by the ID of the instance and produce
just one we need this in order for our
clients to do the search and the
faceting and the slicing and dicing of
the data so they can search for example
for all the instance in au or all the
instance that
the name X when you think about this
problem like okay so in the in the days
of the database you just go to the
database and pick up things if things do
not work well at the cache here and
there when you're in the stream business
what you have to do if you have multiple
partitions in each one of them and you
want to process them like with multiple
instances due to throughput it basically
means that the same and what one of the
key points here is that the partition
key for these two topics is the same so
the instance matrix with the key one
should end up in partition zero in the
instance metadata with the k1 end up in
partition zero now the problem is that
when you work just directly with Kafka
consumers and producers there is no
control over which partitions are you
consuming they are assigned randomly and
so what end up doing what ended up
happening is that your metrics go to one
instance and your metadata goes to
another instance so the merge cannot
happen you just unable to do it now the
trick that you can do is basically you
can read all three partitions from the
metadata topic in each one of the end of
the instances it brings all sorts of
problems like for example lack of memory
and scalability issues and also the
problem that we saw is the startup time
in this situation of your service can go
to like minutes because you need to
recuperate all the metadata for all the
entities for all the clients into one
instance so from the scalability
perspective it's not very good now the
only magic dust that Kafka streams
brings into the game is called code
partitioning what they make sure is that
instead of that you have to read all the
partitions of the metadata in this case
in
to merge to the work they basically take
control of it and they say okay if you
have the same partitioning key and you
have the same number of partitions we're
gonna make sure that these instance will
subscribe to partition zero of topic one
and partition zero of topic two and so
the match can actually happen on this
and you don't have to read all the
metadata in memory in ready to do it
which is exactly what we needed to do so
as I said the the so in order for this
magic to happen you have to have the
same partitioning key you have to have
the same number of partitions in each
topic obviously and you have to have the
same hash function of a producer and
this came as a little bit of a surprise
so in our system in our infrastructure
we have java application and go
application so in this case java
application introduced to the matrix
topic and obligation to the metadata
topic now what we saw what we observed
that the message with the same key for
some reason ended up in the different
partitions and so the Kafka streams
being subscribed to partition 0
partition 0 we're not able to do the
match well turns out that according to
the historical reasons Joe and go
libraries of Kafka used different hash
function in order to know which
partition to send your data to and so it
just doesn't happen the way but Kafka
streams is is excellent it helps you
here so what it does for you it
introduced the operation of repetition
so I'm gonna take all your data that you
have and it's gonna be partition it with
the correct hash function and so your
funk so your metadata will end in the
topic number 0 as it's supposed to be so
the match will happen now as you see
this with with these
basically we can do enrichment at scale
so just because we only have to read
like one partitions from each of the
topics we're basically can scale with
the number of partitions and in case
where you have problems of the hopes
Kafka stories will happily repetition
all your data for you now the only trick
is that they're gonna be a little bit
more Kafka topics with all the work done
we were about to get some rest but then
we understood that we need to deploy
this to production and this was for us
quite simple because what we have is the
masses cluster and so we do the
declarative deployment we just say how
many CPUs we want how many memory and
how many instances of this and each one
of our applications exposes healthcheck
that basically says if the application
is running or it's not running and that
was the and when the health check says
there's not running of course messes
will remove it from the cluster and
we're gonna replace it with the
brand-new that is much better so in case
of Kafka streams as I said since it is a
library all the glue you have to bring
by yourself so like all the services
starts and everything you have to do in
your java application with Kafka you
just start the stream thread and it goes
on its own now the trick is that if the
stream thread dies well your application
things that it's all fine and data just
doesn't flow in so in order to fix the
situation
Kafka streams exposes you the set of
listeners that you can use in order to
manage this situation so in the normal
state Kafka will be like normal normal
situation the only state that you should
be in is running now the problem is that
whenever Kafka and sees the error it can
go to the erroneous state and will never
recover from it if you don't listen to
these state changes you will not be able
to
detect that you're actually not
processing any data another situation
that we saw is that sometimes Kafka
dreams application can do rebalancing
which is normal but sometimes due to
Network flakiness due to cluster
unhealthy state or due to messes
interesting things rebalancing can take
a long time or it just you're in the
rebalancing loop and this situation we
alert because it basically means that
the data does not flowing through and
another set of listeners is used to
announce you how the state restoration
is going so as I said when the
application starts up it needs to pick
up the latest stated head from the Kafka
topic and this process in the normal
situation it just like picks up several
batches and then goes to the end now the
problem is that for example if you have
too much state you can stay in the batch
restore stateful eight minutes at a time
or if you have some partition that has
much more data it's gonna be feeling
like the application does nothing
because you just sit there and chew in
CPU meanwhile the data is not flowing
and so in order for you not to redeploy
the application as I did it's good to
know that it's just restoring the
batches so as for the metrics these are
the state listeners as for the metrics
that we are monitoring we always
monitoring consuming and producing
throughput and we are lower than this
because it basically means if your
processor is working or not we also
alert them missing joins so whenever the
match of the metadata and metrics for
example in our case doesn't happen it
means that there is some data loss it
means that in some topic maybe the
partitions are not right it means that
something weird is going on so we alert
on this and we also learned as I said on
very balanced look because we found out
that it could be freaking
and apart from this the metrics that we
also monitor will be storage specific
metrics mmm Kafka exposes tons of
metrics for you but one that we found
the particularly interesting our so each
aggregation store each store will report
its size so you can understand for
example your data is distributed
uniformly or not and it helps you and
also we have a lot of business specific
logic metrics in there to understand if
we actually say okay we're producing and
then consuming but are we actually doing
any work so this is like a typical
dashboard of our application I'm gonna
be the latest states in the big letters
so you know if everything is going well
there's gonna be a chart that shows like
historical performance of this instance
we're gonna see the throughput of
producer and consumer here this will be
the business metric in this case we're
producing the reports so we know if
there is like a dip in reports maybe we
should alert than this and these two
charts represent the state restorations
is you see for example for one partition
it took four minutes to restore after
one restart which was not very good and
we had to work on this so after tackling
the deployment and everything if you are
successful enough it's time for you to
scale as I said Kafka
streams scales with the amount of
partitions the trick is though that
having the manage cluster which is
cannot just add the partition bar cells
so we need to create the pull request to
do it and also if you just create the
partition the Kafka stream will die for
example if it trying to do the merge
because it's gonna say that in one topic
there is four partition and all three so
the way it should be done is that you
have to shut down your Kafka streams
application apply the change to your
topics and then turn it on
and number of brushes should be the same
so in our case it turns into a very
interesting set of operations okay we
want to migrate from the topic with
three partition the topic with four
partition in this case so first we have
to create a pull request to the Kafka
server to create these new topics we
cannot change the configuration of the
topics as them as it is because we don't
know when this change will be applied by
the team that is managing cluster so and
we cannot shut down
Kafka streams for like hours so first
there is a PR with the new topics then
there is a second PR for the one
application to start pointing to the new
topic and there's a third PR for the
second application to point to the new
topic then we drain the old topics with
the application and then there's the
fourth PR that basically points to all
the new topics all these to say that you
actually with Kafka streams there's a
tendency of doing micro-services there
is a tendency of like having multiple
Kafka topics here and there and so run
books in the documentation is something
I found very valuable in this process
and something we didn't do very well I
should say and another trick that we
found or a rake is that so imagine that
you have a look operation in between of
your topologies so that the source on
the top the sink on the bottoms of the
messages flow top down and there is a
lookup operation where you block for
some reason you go to the database in
the HTTP Co you do something well it
turns out that it's gonna block the
whole topology so like no work will be
done even if your topology is huge and
there's could be some pluralization
happens the nature of stream processing
and the way the Kafka stream handles
messages is top-down depth-first meaning
that they can see the like it picks the
batch of the messages on the source and
up until the last message of this batch
lives the sink nobody will be picked up
so whenever you're blocking your
operation you basically block the whole
topology and data just doesn't flow so
it means that like one of the partitions
or like set of partitions of your
application can have a significant
consumer lag so the lesson learned from
these exercise were like we shouldn't
block which is obvious if we block it's
better to do it in the separate service
Kafka streams really appreciate when you
have a uniform topology in this way it
can optimize the best way the throughput
of your data so if you have like a
blocking call to some service just take
it out extract it to a separate service
and do it there and another thing is
that it's better to distribute the load
as uniform as possibly so for your
partition key choose something that is
super granular like don't go with
account ID because for sure they're
gonna be client but gonna send you a
bunch load of data and it just go
explode one of your partitions and you
have to upsize just the whole
infrastructure based on like one
partition choose something smaller we
went with for example entity ID which
more or less are evenly distributed so
as the summary I'd say that we're quite
happy so we work in with Kafka streams
for about a year now our team I mean so
far we are still building the new
services using Kafka streams which is
good it works reliably whenever you can
start to understand how it works
edge is there crunching the data and you
don't have to feed it it really helps to
know the Kafka very well because
everything is in topic Kafka stream is
beautiful everything isn't but you
really have to understand like how the
topic works like what is the timeout of
the producer and why your application
shows that it has a huge consumer lag
meanwhile it
actually does very well so knowing like
the ins and outs of Kafka really helped
us to work with Kafka streams
efficiently i heavily appreciate that
copper edition of the only magic dust
I've been traumatized by Ruby on Rails
and I hate magic
and the only caveat is that they're
going to be a lot of graphic topics and
this is something you have to be very
honest with especially if you have a
managed cluster and you have operational
people you have to honestly tell them
that you're gonna be created like
probably duplicate and triplicate your
data which is because Kafka streams
crazy topic for you and you also have to
watch really closely because sometimes
just changing the topology a little bit
like thinking it a little forward can
reduce significantly number of topics
that are being created so watch it and
with this I'm open for questions hello
thank you for the presentation it was
really nice I have two questions first
one is about time so when I try to
implement this aggregations over time on
a stream processing platform I had
trouble with the API back then I don't
want to discuss the API has probably
changed but you were doing aggregations
on time which was time insight events
themselves how was that as an experience
was it yeah so right now at least we
didn't have a problem they introduced
the timestamp extractor but basically
you can say if you want the wall time if
you want the stream time of the event or
if you want like inches time of the
message so now you can choose whatever
time you want thank you and the other
one is repetition Inc so if you work
with MapReduce type of frameworks like
spark that's my experience repetition is
something that you wanna do is
yeah don't do as much as you can and you
said that there will be a lot of
repetition again that was from my
experience also something how does that
affect your cluster how do you see that
in production and yeah what does that
mean for your application okay so as you
said we spark there's basically a
shuffling rate that you try to avoid it
as hard as possible like the beauty of
Kafka is of Kafka streams is that with
spark sometimes I had a problem that
shuffling just occurs behind the scenes
and you don't know what's going on there
it just like the whole cluster just kind
of go and with carcass dreams and super
explicit so if it means to partition the
data is gonna create repetition in topic
so at least you know it's like it's much
easier to detect now any so this is
still a problem in terms that whenever
you want to group by things and process
them they're gonna be new partitions
it's unavoidable and another down point
like we so far did indeed a lot of
grouping so we didn't have this problem
but for example when I was also playing
with this I found out that for example
if your groups are not balanced so for
example you do I don't know
banning transactions success and
failures like there's gonna be 99% of
success and like 1% of failures and so
if you do group by this operation it
gonna amp up in two partitions and one
partition will be just a small amount of
data and then album may be huge and this
is something that is still there in the
cluster but and from the how do we
handle it we handle it with care and
love basically our operational team
because otherwise they're gonna prohibit
us to do this so we are super explicit
in terms of like how many data do we
plan to add what will be the throughput
like what will be the pattern of usage
etc so far we didn't so like just
because our cluster is enormous
we didn't soak Africa's dreams producing
too many problems at this point but also
its I like it's being used in just
several teams here and there like it's
not company-wide solution right now
their questions yes thank you I I have a
question regarding state restoration did
you experiment with a number of standby
replicas property and how did that
affect your processing latency and state
restoration process
right so this is something we want to
try the trick there is that we have
normally we have a lot of partitions and
so I don't like I didn't look into how
actually like okay so if you're gonna do
like one standby replica if it's
actually gonna help so if you do the
repetition like what is the chance that
these instance gonna pick up exactly
these partitions so it's something I
want to experiment with exactly to
minimize the number of like the duration
of state restoration but so normally
what we see the state restoration
problem is during the restart so it's
not so much as the repetition is like
when the restart happens you just have
too many things for example in one
partition due to imbalance that it has
to pick up thank you more questions
hi yeah I've got a question regarding
the trying to replicate or create new
environments so the issue is something
might occur within production mean you
want to reproduce it how many different
environments do you have at least in
some way to test something or introduce
a new feature how's the infrastructure
being taken care okay so in general we
have production environment and staging
environments and the art can like they
are the same meaning that they're gonna
be the same configuration of all the
topics in both environments
the data amount obviously will be
different we do not ingest client's data
into staging but since basically so our
infrastructure is meses class right so
we're declarative
meaning that we just have a Yama file
and things are being created for us we
have another one Yama file and topics
are being created for us so the only
thing we actually need to do is like
deploy our application whenever we need
it to be so for us like we as the
company for example we are doing the
disaster recovery once a year and so we
are practise this restoration quite
often in order for it to be efficient
[Music]